that's our next guest against the
cleveland browns in december four
touchdowns that day for kenyon drake and
what an amazing season after the trade
you rarely see a guy get traded in the
middle of the season and do anything you
hit the ground
flying for the arizona cardinals it's
just amazing to see it happen
congratulations on your great year thank
you for and uh appreciate you allowing
me to be here no we're glad that oh i
mean why like explain to people out
there like you know you're with miami
people like uh
he's good he has some moments but then
you go to arizona and we're all like
whoa one of the best running backs in
football you know like in your own ways
like why is that what what happens
football wise um just having a
great support staff around me from my
representation that uh you know was with
with me every step of the way my
transition um to everybody at arizona
cardinals organization that um you know
allowed me to kind of uh go there be
myself help me flourish um collar was
you know that first game i had no clue
you know any of the terminology i was
just out there just
playing hard running fast and you know
he would i would be like you know where
i need lineup you just tell me line up
left go right so you're breaking the
huddle and you're not even sure even on
running plays you're like you're like
i'm in his air like all right just tell
me what i got to do right because i was
there for three days like you know it
didn't really stick to me but um like i
said i had the offensive lineman you
know uh before the game started you know
just helping me with some of the
terminology to you know just put me to
the best situation to be successful yeah
and that was amazing that short week
thursday night game against the 49ers
162 yards from scrimmage and a touchdown
and it stunned everybody that uh you
were able to do that right away and you
carried it all year long and made a huge
impact on that cardinals offense what
what did you see from kyler murray that
impressed you the most um
his his ability to just block out a lot
of the noise around him i mean
you know former heisman winner first
round first pick uh you can you would
think that you know that type of guy
would you know have a air bottom or you
know just kind of move a little
differently but you know he was real
down to earth um you know went out there
had on his business and got better you
know every single week you know
it's very rare to see a rookie
quarterback come in and have that type
of success have that type of
comfortability but uh kingsbury uh you
know was able to put him in the best
situation to be successful and
he used all the weapons and guys around
him to his uh disposal and you know had
a lot of success is the like does the
talent like of kyler murray just like
pop to you as soon as you see him yeah
it's really it's really kind of amazing
like his arm strength he could right
kind of just fall in the awkward
position and just flick it just flicking
right and the ball just pops out of his
arm but uh he he has a great ability to
just you know also you know run the ball
at very keen uh situations and then he's
he i don't know is he's he's fast but
it's like he gets to that speed so quick
like two steps yeah he's he's he's full
speed you know his celebration on
madden's probably like a 99 or something
but he's uh he's an amazing guy i'm
probably going to see him later on this
week so you know can't wait to you know
catch up with him is this the first time
ever you've been on a team where maybe
the quarterback's faster than you uh
well i'm not going to say
i knew you were good
i'm not gonna go that far but he
definitely has a lot of speed
he might get you off the line but you
think you'll run them down oh yeah now
for sure
how weird was it for you to go to a
place where they got david johnson he's
the guy he's getting paid like the guy
you know and now all of a sudden you're
the guy well what what's the dynamic
like between you as the newcomer and the
guy who's there that they've made the
investment in um he he's definitely one
of the more down-to-earth people one of
them
probably
better guys in the league just the way
he carries himself week in and week out
from the injuries that he's sustained to
me coming in and having a lot of success
on the team um he took everything in
stride uh you know great family man and
um like i said
a great football player but i feel like
he's a better man and
you know i i wish nothing but the best
in you know in the rest of his career
and everything that he uh has to
accomplish because i was definitely
impressed by the way he carried himself
you got we're back in miami you had the
miami miracle right like you and i have
talked about this before is that the
number one thing people stop you for as
far as is it that play is it alabama
did he get some free drinks every now
and then because of it the funny thing
is i had a lot of so i went to the miami
heat game on monday and i just had a lot
of people come up to me tell me how you
know uh you know they miss seeing me in
a dolphins uniform happy for the success
that i've had and you know that genuine
happiness that you know you see from
strangers you know even though they're
fans of the team fans of me um it's
definitely something i really appreciate
and that's why i love miami a lot of
people um i love the culture and that's
another thing also that i uh uh decided
to be a part of because when i came down
here um the first thing i did
yesterday after i got down here was uh
get with the ocean conservancy and try
to you know do all i can to you know
give back to the city that gave so much
to me um protecting our environment our
way of life you're going to wake up
you're going to wake up
that's what i mean so i'm with you let's
fight it let's go let me hear more about
it yeah so ocean conservancy uh we there
was a 54 ton gold that we were able to
reach yesterday when we went to the
historic virginia beach to clean up um
eight over eight million tons of plastic
enter our ocean every day that's enough
to fill up fill up hard rock stadium
every day right and that's horrible um
it's it's i just wanted to continue to
do my part to bring more awareness use
this platform that i have especially
being here to super bowl in miami um
like i said in a city that you know gave
so much to me when i you know came here
as a young 22 uh fresh phrase rookie and
um you know just do all i can like i
said to give back uh protect the ocean
protect the wildlife uh protect the
beautiful way of life that the miami
people uh live and you know that's
through the ocean and sure making sure
you know we do our part for not just
today but for future generations to come
he's the man man i'm just telling you
it's one of the best guys uh human
beings in all of football ocean
conservancy
uh conservation i should say i mean
you're a good guy i spent a day with him
at the boys and girls club here in miami
last offseason i mean the kids love him
he's like santa claus when he walks into
the room all right so uh really though
like proud of you what you did man just
want to say that and then like this what
you're doing right here i'm going to
start like
pulling this down so i'm going to start
talking let's see i want to write some
checks you know i want to write some
checks i will i will i don't got big
time quarterback money i got kyler kyler
murray money but i will and like really
if i ever could be a part of the cause
it'd be stuff like this so good for you
i really appreciate it yeah you the man
so uh you're gonna be a free agent
perfect time to be a free agent the way
you played down the stretch four
touchdowns against the browns 166 yards
against the seahawks what's your
objective going into free agency uh just
take it every day
every day one day at a time
like i was telling somebody else that
asked me this question just recently um
football is the ultimate team sport so
obviously i want to put myself in the
best position to have the best guys
around me the best um you know
individuals in general not just football
players but men yeah um but at the same
time you got to understand that behind
the game there is a big business and i
want to make sure i do the
the right thing for not just right now
but uh for the trajectory of my family
you know i play this game to change the
life of the people around me that i love
and care about so
um
you know i'm gonna you know do the thing
obviously that you know helps put me in
the best situation for football but you
know i have to go out here and and do
the things that like i said will change
the trajectory of my family amen to that
too listen
the fans applaud when the billionaires
who own the teams make their savvy moves
and make more money for their families
but for whatever reason when players
start talking about it
being selfish no you guys have a limited
window you are putting your health on
the line every time you go out there and
we always say it do what you have to do
to get paid the most you can for what
you do because that window is going to
close and you may as well get what you
can while that window's up for sure and
i definitely believe in that um you know
i feel like
some people may get a bad rap about it
and kind of go about it in not the the
most positive way sure but everybody's
goal is the same and i try to do it the
best way i can and like i said to
support the people that that got me to
this position um that's the only way i
know how to do it so
when that decision you know is to be
made i feel like i will be prepared to
make the best decision because of the
people i have around me all right well
we got to let you go i want you to pick
a winner of this game though i know you
played the niners twice before we let
you go go ahead hurry because we got to
go to cover uh chiefs they just you
can't you can't stop you can only hope
and contain them there you go yeah they
have too many weapons he can't root for
a team in the division
well he's a free agent maybe he's not
going to be there we don't know all
right hey great seeing you kenyan
congratulations on all your success
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports